when we begin in Ukraine where Air Raid
Sirens have been ringing out across the
country this Christmas Day officials
issued an alert covering all regions of
Ukraine the president zielinski has
called for Unity in his holiday address
to the nation he says residents will
create their own Christmas miracle by
showing that they remain strong in the
face of Russian attacks
no Kamikaze drones can extinguish the
Christmas Dawn we will see its glow even
underground in a bomb shelter we will
fill our hearts with warmth and light no
missiles can hurt them they will break
against our steel spirit and our fight
will continue unabated it's not
threatened by planned or emergency
blackouts and we will never feel a lack
of courage and invincibility
we will celebrate our holidays as always
we will smile and rejoice as always
the difference is one
we will not wait for a miracle because
we will create it ourselves
well let's speak to Charles Stratford
who's in the capital Q for us Charles
rousing words there from zelenski even
amid these Air Raid Sirens
that's right yes
um aeroid Sirens I suppose about half an
hour ago now Countrywide we heard them
loud
and clear across Kiev
um let's be uh put this in context and
and draw a line under the fact that
these Air Raid Sirens are these alerts
are common they happen virtually every
day we so far have heard no reports of
any strikes either in Kiev or across the
country but we will wait and see because
of course we know the kind of pressures
that the Ukrainian Authority the
Ukrainian military have had in recent
weeks in protecting vital infrastructure
from these russian-launched Kamikaze and
cruise missile attacks around about a
thousand of them in the last two and a
half months
um we know that there are still millions
of people who have no electricity that
are having to endure rolling blackouts
and have poor if any heating at all as
these winter temperatures continue to
drop there have been a couple of lines
from
Ukrainian authorities in the last sort
of 12 hours or so saying that the
situation remains critical for
electricity that's just in Kiev and
significant across the country as all
efforts focus on trying to get as much
of this infrastructure back up and
running
meanwhile um there are as as we've been
reporting pretty much every day now
ongoing intense fighting in Flashpoint
towns on the front line in the East that
town of bakmut we know has seen some of
the most intense fighting in recent
weeks that is ongoing strategically
important for both sides if the Russians
were to take it and it's important to
recognize that they've made very few or
very little gain there in recent weeks
but if they were to take it that would
give them a clearer path to hitting the
two largest cities still under full
Ukrainian control in the Donetsk region
those cities of cremator and sloviansk
we're hearing also reports of ongoing
fighting to the south of Bahamut that
town of avdievka that incredibly is so
close to russian-controlled Donetsk the
city of Donetsk and yet by and large in
the 10 months since this war started
there's been very little movement there
but the town now on under heavy attack
and also very interestingly there has
there are increasing reports of the
ukrainians shelling the town of Tok Mac
now this town sits south of zaparisia
between ukrainian-controlled zaparisia
and russian-controlled melitor pull
there were reports that the ukrainians
are trying to potentially make a push
towards melatopol and we understand that
the reason why talk Mac is being so
heavily shelled by the ukrainians is
they're trying to cut supply lines now
back to those attacks these ongoing
drone and missile attacks that are
hitting all this infrastructure across
the country we yesterday spent the day
with a mobile air defense unit around
Kiev and this is our report
foreign
Skyward and on high alert this Soviet
anti-aircraft gun was built in 1982
the man at its controls are members of a
mobile air defense unit trying to
protect the Ukrainian capital and
surrounding area from Russian so-called
Kamikaze drone and missile attacks
some of the ammunition was taken from a
similar Russian weapon captured around
butcher in the early days of the war
other soldiers carry portable
heat-seeking Soviet post-soviet and
Western Stinger missiles
the commander says they are effective up
to a range of six kilometers but often
find it difficult to latch onto the
drones that Russia is using to Target
Ukraine's electricity grid
Shahid 131 and 136 Kamikaze drones are
low speed visible and loud but they have
a small Heat Signature it can be
difficult to lock onto the Target and
the missile might miss
anti-aircraft guns work most effectively
against the Shaheed but they have a
problem if the Drone flies at night or
conditions of poor visibility
Russian forces have carried out at least
a thousand drone and cruise missile
attacks targeting energy infrastructure
in the last two and a half months
most like this one are intercepted
but many gets through so millions of
ukrainians are suffering blackouts and
poor Heating in freezing winter
conditions
Ukraine's Western backers have sent air
defense weapons such as this naysam
system and last week the U.S announced
it is supplying a patriot missile system
but training how to use it can take
months
and one missile costs up to four million
dollars
the commander of this unit says it will
be used to predict only the most
important potential targets and cannot
be deployed to intercept drones and
cruise missiles
as we were filming this mobile air
defense unit
the sound of a siren can be heard in the
distance and as a result as you can
imagine
these men are now on the Move
we were not allowed to follow the
soldiers because at the risk of giving
away their locations but in another
field close to Kiev this mobile air
defense unit practices using a machine
gun with a range of around three
kilometers it can easily take down the
Kamikaze drones that flies around 160
kilometers an hour only to get Eyes On
First
drones are less difficult than missiles
but there are observational difficulties
because they can fly over forests that
hide them or over busy roads where their
approach noise is drowned out by traffic
foreign despite the challenges they face
there are hundreds of men like these
across the country constantly ready for
a radio alert focused on the skies
Charles Strafford Al Jazeera Kiev region